hello and welcome to this video playing
each wife each - me - I know I spoiled a
fantastically terrible game last time
yeah it was really very weird I don't
know he does play a movie on it so let's
go for something else
experimental mode I have played them
Queens gambit accepted from time to time
but I'm really far away from being
knowledgeable I thought that this isn't
all that great actually with the knight
on c6 but I don't exactly know why I
don't know why
it cannot go 95 that is definitely a
difference you should be for maybe and
and against f3 something weird like 95
or something like that an IG - it looks
awesome but ok I'm kind of inventing
this now I don't really have a clue how
it is played Regis castles that's a bit
cheeky
hmm
1995 is probably good huh really odd
so my bishop he is hanging but I'm
attacking his Knight and if he plays the
night I can play with each with a quick
age five probably after taking on c3
like Knight G - takes on c3 be takes age
five something like that could work
really tough to say what he's going to
play Knight e4 Knight takes Queen takes
h4 I think is fine I have h5 coming and
I can castle next move okay this I think
is completely uncritical and quite
obviously so why I'm getting it wrong
which is of course possible okay I did
not have this so much on the radio yeah
h5 is can of
kind of obvious
g5 there should be seven and then what
g5 is mandatory almost okay so I take
this maybe just what does he do their
queen takes
hey this is also not bad if I take it's
actually it's actually a check this is
some this I did not really this didn't
really register I mean it's not bad if I
take one G for words I wanted more
I don't know I mean this is okay but
pancakes I asked to take on take on g4
with the pawn I guess but I'm not really
good at guessing his moves I mean okay
yeah now I'm probably not going to trade
Quincy I can looks like there are
attacking chances so let's go for it
Luke I'm blundering Bishop g5 I've
learned the Bishop g5 I have got Queen
f3 which I didn't see beforehand to be
honest but I was kind of in ed more like
okay I'm never guessing any office we
had moved so I'm going to just just play
quickly and then I have the now
blundered it so here this position is
excellent
okay it's going to be a pain yeah let's
see I don't have much time
and wasn't the best way to flame it's
almost certain no that was not good at
all
and I have to win this ending somehow
I'm sure that this was the best but you
have to set some problems we never take
it and he takes no it's just difficult
to make anything I would have it's
difficult to even make play for trick
I drawing this is really bad many play
to such come on I mean how many mistakes
can you make and not lose I mean it's
all my fault of course just have to
punish this bad play I mean I should
just it all was
it's still a draw but that's kind of
pointless here what he's doing yeah
might as well play down to the end it
was really bad I mean like roughly here
know roughly here I'm just winning
basically it's got a really bad King
position and bad bishop on c1 and so on
it's just like it's completely
completely terrible yeah it's like plus
a middle unit plus five a rock edge for
wasn't exactly difficult but this is
also this should also win simply okie
eight I'm taking Queen b6 yeah but I
mean yeah this is this is already this
is already awkward because I don't have
a good Queen move yeah this is this this
is probably strong than f5 it's not very
intuitive it's all nice and good if the
engine shows that but it's not it's not
super simple yeah okay Luke eighth row
before certainly as this is it's just
it's just over all right I mean this is
all this is end of game you just win win
big material
yeah he is back him and I don't have
anything great oh yeah this is just
equal ish I feel I can maybe still win
the endgame but the five is a little
weak but rubric endings have such a wide
drawing margin that some yeah what king
did seven good for I don't see how this
would win yeah this is probably still
better because if here I can go up and
dis hangs so this is probably this is
better yeah I didn't see that g5 was
hanging it was pretty clear that if I
have to go back like in the game that I
cannot win like even if the engine gives
an advantage I don't think you can win
this is just a wrong
yeah pretty awful yeah thanks for
watching